ryan leaf here on the rich eisen show
how are you ryan can you hear me now
the rich eyes okay oh wow oh gosh thank
god this is great thank you
[Laughter]
all right um i i set you up you know on
uh like uh like like uh i guess your
your a first ball on the t there at uh
mountain gate so
um so let me ask you this question ryan
uh what did you make of the calvin
ridley
news
well of course we've been asking players
to be um more up front about this when
they're going through what they're going
through and not
um
feel ashamed and
and because of the stigma that exists so
we've we've asked players to do this so
i was extremely proud of him
uh extremely proud of lane johnson over
the weekend discussing it with jay
glazer on fox nfl sunday
all of those things what naomi osaka did
this summer
simone biles those
players
on a national platform speaking out
about the same things that they go
through
like everybody else i think is exactly
what needs to continue to happen the
spotlight needs to be shown on it it
needs to destigmatize it therefore
anybody now
people say it's easier for them they're
in the spotlight i think it actually
does a a better job for us because when
i was going through it i was
uh i had to confront it um because when
i screwed up and when i was going
through mental health issues and and and
self-medicated and dealt with it the
wrong way everybody saw it rich and i
was confronted and had
consequences to my actions and had to
seek the help there's a lot of
individuals that go through it in the
in the dark in the shadows and then
they're no longer around because they
just disappear so i love what he did i
love that he's taking care of himself
and and i hope that everybody else who's
seeing it knows it's okay to not be okay
ask for the help and do that regardless
of if you're a starting nfl wide
receiver or if you're somebody who just
is dealing with the mental illness uh
like everybody else
now uh i you you know how i feel about
the subject and i feel about you so i'm
what i'm about to say is what i hear
from folks who don't quite grasp
the seriousness of this because there is
no caste there's no mri there's no
crutch there's no nothing it's just
somebody struggling with something you
can't see right
so
what i hear in responses like
why
do you need to step away
for something that's been created
potentially in a world that you
willingly
walked into you wanted you dreamed for
this moment
how can you not deal with it what do you
say to that ryan yeah that's extremely
hard and harsh from anybody who believes
that i think what they're trying to say
is that you are what i wish i could be a
professional football player a
millionaire and those two things don't
fix anything
money tends to exacerbate probably a lot
of things that that exist in your life
and so those that have that viewpoint
they're projecting something something
that's going on inside them and they may
need to take a a good look at uh what's
going on with them
that's why you got to push those things
out when you hear those types of things
and they're going to be backlash like
that
because you're a commodity when you're
on an nfl team so you can't actually
have real life problems like everybody
else um
and i went through the exact same thing
i didn't know what it was rich when i
was going through it right i just
thought i was a bad football player and
therefore uh i should be you know
dragged by the media and dragged by the
fans and everything like that i didn't
realize that i was clinically depressed
right that i was going through those
things that
that that i would be diagnosed with
later in life and so when you don't know
what it is
it's just as hard as the person who's
viewing it going i can't see a crutch i
can't see a cast it's the same thing for
the individual looking in the mirror
going
what's wrong with me i just thought i
was lazy i thought i was sad i just
didn't think my career panned out the
way i and it didn't but
i also was going through something
that that everybody else goes through
from time to time in their lives and
that's dealing with mental illness i
just didn't know how to do it and i also
did not know how to ask for help and i
applaud both of those gentlemen over
this weekend coming forward talking
about it in a public way well and and i
you know i think there might be some
some uh another interesting aspect to
this is that the female athletes get a
heck of a lot more grief than the male
athletes on this
um you know and and and
uh or male athletes get like the you
should be masculine and tough enough to
get through it
you know but honestly i i don't mean to
keep focusing on what the negative
reactions are
but the reason why i'm doing that ryan
is because i think i'd like to show
those who might be sitting there
thinking calvin just suck it up you know
you went to alabama how did you not know
that the spotlight in the nfl or that's
what we're assuming what it is too
as to what might be causing him to step
away from football you know a dream come
true for so many other people
trying to maybe through poking
uh holes in what might be coming in the
direction of of folks like
osaka and
simone biles or or these two football
players that we're talking about ryan
you know what i'm saying
yeah and and i understand that you know
this last year for a lot of people
you know the covid
situation could have affected a ton of
people regardless of what you did for a
living like things have been going well
in my life
with my family professionally everything
rich but the last 18 months
it's been hard right because my disease
tells me
oh you got this handled ryan you're the
big strong football player that you got
it handled and when your disease tells
you that and then
everybody else tells you around covert
19 to be socially distanced
my recovery is all based in fellowship
you know it really is it's about being
with other people like-minded
individuals uh who can relate with one
another so it's been a tough 18 months
and i had some of the best things in my
life going on yet i was
feeling the remnants of that of that
depression and i think a lot of times
where the skeptics get really really bad
at this when you come out and talk about
it and people oh that's cool he's
addressing it
people just assume it goes away because
you develop the tools to deal with it
this is an ongoing thing right it just
doesn't stop once you admit that it
exists and you go about your business
and trying to live in that recovery side
of it you still have bad days it still
exists and you have to address it the
same way like calvin ridley can take
some time away and and sure enough come
back and play really well and have about
a depression or whatever exists in his
terms
down the line and that's going to be
okay it's just astonishing that people
stop like treating people like they
actually have a mental illness once
they've talked about it and have
addressed it in some way shape or form
it's a lifetime commitment obviously
ryan leaf here on the rich eisen show so
uh
uh what would you what would you cancel
calvin ridley uh from afar clearly
you're not
you're not there um talking to him i
imagine um but what would you what would
you counsel calvin ridley
uh to do or or or courses of action for
him
right well i'm not privy to any you know
reasoning what kind of uh diagnosis or
or really what it is at all he just says
he needs time for himself he's dealing
with some emotional and personal issues
and and i i just commend him on doing it
right making a statement about this is
why i'm stepping away from a public
place right a public football team to
address the things i need in my personal
life with my family and everything like
that and when i'm healthy enough just
like if i have rolled an ankle when i'm
healthy enough i'll be back out there
trying to contribute
and make the atlanta falcons a winning
team so i love what he's doing he's got
to block out all the noise and if he's
seeing a therapist or a counselor or
somebody they'll be counseling him the
same way hey you know we we what other
people think of us is none of our
business it's about what we see in the
mirror and how we go about it and that's
where true humility becomes
uh who you are right the understanding
you understand who you are regardless of
what anybody else thinks says or does
and that's where you develop the most
healthy version of yourself and i i
commend them again for for you know have
most people don't have to make a
statement to the public about the mental
health issue they're going through right
but he plays a public sport and there's
different circumstances around that as
an individual
a few more minutes left with ryan leaf
here on the rich eisen show in the few
minutes i have left um how difficult uh
is it to do what trevor simeon did
cooper rushed wow i mean how yeah it's
how tough is that extremely hard it's
extremely hard because you don't get the
reps in practice that's the biggest
thing i i was on the radio last night
talking about this you know sean payton
is an unbelievable uh head coach in
terms of how he schemes offensively
always has been and with that huge play
calling she he has on the sideline i
swear to god he probably had a whole
section that that just read
trevor's favorite place and when he got
in he just ran those that he knew trevor
was really really good at and they
accomplished it for whatever reason sean
payton and the new orleans saints and
and and coach allen on the defensive
side of everything boy they just have
tom brady and tampa bay's number during
the regular season right so that has to
be tempered a little bit but you know
all these backup quarterbacks that got
in and got opportunities i tell you what
the talent is always there the reason
you're the nfl is because you have
talent from a to z they're good it's
just a matter of whether or not they get
the opportunity and when they get that
opportunity they make the most of it you
know if drew bledsoe doesn't go out
i don't know i don't know if we see tom
brady that season and i don't know what
that looks like down the future but when
that opportunity presented itself tom
jumped at it and then kept excelling
through the process and there were
opportunities this weekend for guys to
do that themselves and it was fun to see
especially as a guy that really
struggled in the nfl as a quarterback to
see guys have success when that
opportunity presented well i mean at
least trevor simeon's done it before
right and can actually look at at sean
payton in some sort of a meeting when
sean payton has that meeting with trevor
simeon and say these are my favorite
plays this is what i love so in just in
case of emergency they can break that
glass like they did in week eight and
the same with geno smith cooper rush had
never started in the nfl before neither
had mike white who even got a cup of
coffee against the patriots and that was
very eye-opening for a lot but cooper
had cooper russian hadn't thrown a pass
to the nfl he threw three back in 2017.
that's insane extremely you know he was
extremely accurate and when you listen
to those with those coaches uh during
the off season in particular during fall
camp especially when dak was out right
kind of rehab in that shoulder they were
really they were really sold on cooper
rush his act accuracy the um
relationship with his wide receivers and
they have made maybe one of the best
wide receiver rooms in the cup uh in the
nfl right when you're talking about
cooper uh lamb and uh and wilson those
guys they're just they're special
players and you know that shows how how
good cooper is and how they use adapted
because a year ago when dak went down
andy dalton was in and they looked like
a shell of themselves offensively they
just apparently had to go out and get
the new redhead they got a new red rifle
yeah they can't do it without ginger you
know what i mean so um
so i guess last one for you here it's
just the thing i love about the nfl it's
just again the the is the team it's it's
the team effort to you know and how
how when when you have a team win how
much it how it feels and then when you
have a team win that celebrates the
individual achievement of somebody who
works so hard and the team has a front
row seat as how hard this person works
to either stay with the team or work
hard to make sure that the team isn't
let down when they have that opportunity
and then they win what what do you think
what was it like in that locker room for
the jets and for the
cowboys and for the saints and for the
seahawks what do you think it was like
for those dubs
well i think that's it's it's the
continuation the fighting the spirit
right when you're in that locker room
and the season seems to be going down
the wrong way and you all are still
doing the work every single day when
you're getting huge paychecks yet you
still come to work and try to get better
mike white with the opportunity in new
york and then to see him do it when they
got down 10 late in the game right for
the defense to step up and get the big
interception against joe burrow and then
turn it into points do something really
fun with the philly special for the
two-point conversion mike white
celebrating like that the rookie michael
carter running all over the place i mean
it
if you're in that locker room it's
exactly what robert saul has been
talking about and especially if you're
jets fans out there this team had no
quit in them and i think years past when
the season started to go downhill uh and
uh rolling rocks started picking up more
and more moss
they tended to quit and this didn't
happen they're playing arguably one of
the best teams in the afc yesterday and
they just fought tooth and nail to get
the win same with seattle with geno
smith and that defense against
jacksonville all of those things are
huge you know it makes dallas a very big
contender when your backup quarterback
can go and do what he did mike and
parsons may have been the best draft
pick last year in the draft and what in
the impact he's had on that team
defensively so uh just a ton of fun uh
new orleans continues to you know i
think that that hangover is going to
ultimately set in when they know they've
lost jameis winston for the season with
the acl but trevor simeon really really
stepped up in a big way against the
defending champions and the goat
well ryan look forward to hearing your
call on westwood one sunday night
football the titans in their first game
without derrick henry and then obviously
taking on a rams team with von miller on
it that's going to be a heck of a game i
looks into i look forward to your call
yeah uh what an opportunity you know um
i don't know what to say man i'm just
i'm just really excited about it this is
uh this is a pretty cool kid a kid
moment for me i love it uh yeah i
appreciate it you deserve it you deserve
it let's talk down the line take care of
yourself ryan you'll be you'll be
welcome all right hey fellas what up
ryan what up buddy talk soon bro there's
ryan leaf everybody hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here